So we end up with an objectized structure of
the virtual memory manager that looks like this. That you
have a process object that is equivalent to a PCB
in the traditional setting. And of course there's a TLB
on the processor that's going to be maintained even in
hardware or software depending on the architecture. Because architectures do
it in hardware, some architectures leave it up to the
software to manage the TLB. And the region object Is,
as they said, a portion of the
address piece. So essentially, the page table data
structure is split into these region objects.
And the regionobjects, there is a file cache
manager that knows the location of the
files on the backing store that corresponds to
the a particular region. So the file
cash manager is responsible for backing this region.
And this file cache manager interacts with the
DRAM manager in order to get a physical
frame because when there is a page fault
in a particular region, the file cache manager has
to contact the DRAM object in order to
get a physical page frame. And, once it gets
the physical page frame, it kicks off this
COR, which we said is the cached object representation.
Of a page. It [UNKNOWN] this COR object to say, well, here is a page frame for
you and here is the page on the disk. Go do it. And it is the responsibility of
the cached object representation to populate the physical page
frame by doing I/O with the disk in order
to move this page from the disk representation into
a memory representation. So, this is sort of the
structure of the objectized virtual memory manager and
depending on the region of the virtual memory space
that you're accessing the path that a particular
page fault may take will be different. if you're
accessing a page that is in the green
region then this is a path that is going to
be taken by the page fault handler and
similarly... If the page fault happens to be in
the purple region then this is the path that's going to
be taken by the page fault handler. So, logically given
the structure, let's think about what is the work flow
in handling a page fault with this objectized structure of
the virtual menu manager. The third T1 is executing poor
guy, and it incurs a page fault. And when it
incurs a page fault, it goes to a process object.
And the process object is able to say, say given
the virtual page number, what region is that
particular page fault falling into? So, that's the
region that we want to go to in order
to service the page fault. So that region object
is then going to contact the file cache
manager. That corresponds to this region object and
to the file and the file cache manager
is going to do two things. One, it's going to see
what exactly is the backing file for that particular
virtual that is missing. So it may be that it
is a file that contains multiple pages. And so it's
going to say file and offset. And that is going
to be the information that has to be passed
on to the COR object. Saying that, here is a
file, and here is the offset in the file. And
that's where the faulty page content can be found on
the storage device. And of course FCM has to get a physical frame. So it
contacts the DRAM object in order to get a physical frame. And so once it
has the physical frame and it has the actual location of the file
then the COR object can preform the IO and pull the
data from the disc into the DRAM. And so
now the p frame, the page frame that has
been allocated for backing this particular virtual page, has
now populated because of the I/O being complete. So
the green arrows is showing you the completion of the
I/O. As a result of that, you've got the
page frame containing the contents of the virtual page
that was missing in the first place. And once
that is available, then the FCM can indicate to the
region that your page fault service is complete. And
at that point, the region can go through the
process object in order to update the TLB, in
order to indicate that now there is a mapping
between the virtual page and the physical frame that
is being populated in physical memory And now the
process can be resumed. So this is the, the
flow of information in order to make the process
runnable again, which faltered on the first place on a,
on a virtual page that is missing in physical memory.
So, now that we have this flow, and we also
mentioned that the cluster object has a single representation. When it
is a region, it's a region. Now how do we
replicate a region object? Should this be a singleton object,
should we replicate it, should this region object be a
singleton object, should it be replicated? If you're going to replicate it,
should it be replicated for every core or a
set of processors of, of a group of processors and
so on? These are all the design decisions. That
the operating system designer has to make. So let's look
at the process object. The process object is mostly
read-only and you can replicate it one per CPU. It's
like a process control block, and you can make it
one per CPU. And all the cores on the CPU
can share this process object because ultimately, The
TLB is a common entity for the entire
processor and since the processed object is updating
the TLB, we can have a single processed object
that manages the TLB. What about the region
object? Well, let's think about this. Now region
represents a portion of the address space. Now
a portion of the address space Maybe traversed by
more than one thread. So, a set of threads
that are running on a group of processors may
actually access a portion of this address space. And
we don't know a priori, how many threads may
actually access a particular region. It's something that may
have to evolve. Over time, but it is definitely
a candidate for partial replication. That is, it is
in the critical path of a page four, so let's
partial replicate the region, not one per
processor, but maybe for a group of processors,
because a group of processors may be running
threads that are accessing the same portion of
the address space, and so we will
replicate this region object one... For every group
of processors. And the granularity of replication decides
the exploitable concurrency from parallel page fault handling.
Now, the interesting thing to notice is that the degree
of replication and the design decision that we take for
how we cluster, the degree of clustering that we choose
for every one of these objects is independent of one
another. So when we talk about the process object, we
said that well, the process object can be one per
CPU. And I said for region object could be applicated
for a group of processes. Now what about the FCM
object, FCM object is backing A region. There
may be multiple replicas of this region, but
all of those regions are backed by the same FCM. And therefore, what we can do
is, the portion of the address space that
is being backed by a particular FCM can
be partioned. So, we can go for a
partioned representation of this FCM. Where competition represents
the portion of the agro space that is managed
by this particular FCM. So, you can see that there
is a degree of freedom in how we choose
to replicate process object, how you we choose to the
region objects. Of course we're partitioning the region objects,
but once we've partitioned it, how we have replications for
each, each of these partitioned regions is something that
is up for grabs as an OS designer. And similarly,
for the file cache manager, because it's backing
a specific region, we can go for a partitioned
representation of the FCM. And what about the
COR, the Cached Object Representation now? Now, this object
is the one that is really dealing with
physically entities. It is actually doing the IO from
the disk into the physical memory. And since we
are dealing with physical entities, it may be appropriate
to have a true shared object for cached
object representation. And the, all the I/O is
going to be managed by this cached object
representation. Even though I'm showing you two different boxes
here, in principle it could be a singleton
object that is managing all of the I/O
activity that corresponds to the virtual memory management.
And what about the DRAM object? Now, the DRAM
object you can have several representations for the
DRAM object depending on how the physical memory
is managed. For example, we may have at
least one representation of the DRAM object for every
DSM piece that you have in a single node's portion of the physical memory. So in
other words, We can break up the entire
physical memory that's available in the entire system into
the portions that are managed individually by each
processor. And there could be a DRAM object that
corresponds to the physical mapped memory that is managed
by each of those. processors, but you can go
even finer than that if it is appropriate, but
it is a design decision that is up to
the designer. So we come up with an replicated
process object, a partial replication for the region object,
a partitioned representation for the FCM object,
and maybe a trued shared object for COR,
and several representations - For the DM object.
So this is one way of thinking about
it, but the nice thing about this objectized
structure is that when we designed the objectized
structure, we did not have to think about
how we could replicate it when we actually
populate these objects. That is a level of design decision that could be...
[INAUDIBLE], because of the secret source, that's
available in tornadoes is a cluster object.